foreign
welcome to an extra spicy episode of
careful boys today we have with us Mr
Anthony it looks like it's so spicy it's
gonna [__] you up it does try it
this is like the regular one see it's
the color they just make you they go wow
yeah don't get cocky bro hey here's a
here's a hot question speaking of spice
oh you're opening up another one are you
laughing at me I thought you're gonna
eat one today I know but there's more
coffee
gotta have your coffee with your donut I
already ate three that is a check bait
very logical you know when there's
coffee you gotta have a donut wait that
means if me and you ate three not
everyone only a one I had two one I'll
have three
I didn't have any knives that's why oh
my God these are this is like a
briefcase with a million dollars in it
it's Kevin for those man thank you Kevin
[Music]
all right what's um if you can answer
this let me know what do you do for a
Klondike bar
almost anything this will put the donut
on top of every napkin by the way
what the hell is that yeah all right
what do you do if you know that your
friend
is abusive to his partner wait what
oh girl whoa what would I do physically
verbal or what yeah if it was a girl my
female friend was beating up her
boyfriend I'd laugh yeah if it was
a male friend beating up his girlfriend
I called the cops you would call the
straight up cops I ain't no rap for your
friend no I ain't no rat
ain't no rat you're literally ratting
him out
but the cops you're literally rounding
out to the cop my friend just so
happened to be a sheriff so I'm talking
to him as a friend and what he does with
his information is up to him it's up to
him I ain't call him I'm [__] no rap
yeah you know that's true that's to be a
sheriff way down now I like that
loophole
why no cop though let's yeah I mean
let's say it is it is physical abuse
yeah like I said if it's a girl I laugh
at his [__] ass you hear a rumor or you
see the girls let's just say you just
know for a fact I know like what do you
mean like came to that conclusion why
the [__] are we friends like that like
you I don't think we would be friends
because you didn't because you didn't
know that if it was a guy friend I first
asked my friend all right I'll first ask
what'd she do to deserve it yeah
that's a valuable question you never
asked that [__] yeah you act like you're
on their side you know what did she call
you because you're trying to you're
trying to fish information dude that's
what you're doing I'm trying to be on
his side so he tells me everything oh so
he can have a conversation with a person
it happens to be a sheriff if a guy
[__] you [__] girlfriend up he's not
gonna be like yeah did that [__] he's
gonna be like no no no you know what
happened she made me do it you know like
and then you go oh tell me more and then
he'll be like yeah so that's that's Joe
fishing information he's like she burnt
the toast yeah yeah or if he was like
nah man this [__] [__] she was so
mad at me because she made oatmeal in
the morning and she was balling it up
and she chucked that [__] burned my body
dude and I'll be like oh she abused you
that's why I abused her and I'm all like
it doesn't justify it but I understand
both of you guys need better help so use
my promo code right now Joe 10 and go to
betterhelp.com
hey that's a good solution yeah
counseling couples counseling see that's
different but then if it's more like she
burnt the toast then I'm all like bug
let's call the cops
it's called my share a friend who burns
toes
I'm like that's [__] up dude that's an
emergency dude you gotta yeah that's not
ready you call the cops too oh no
um I think um not because he doesn't
believe in burnt toast okay it's gonna
be like let's do Ayahuasca together
that's right that's exactly what I do no
if I found out
dang that's kind of crazy I don't know
if I would like you found out you let's
say you found out I was whooping Geo's
ass every day
um
but you can't take down bar bro what are
you gonna do dude I don't know if I
would call the cops though because how
do I know but I know for sure it's true
yeah it's true maybe one day one day you
you've been seeing Joe come in with
bruises oh and then I'll show what's
going on and then one day you stayed
late at the office and then you saw me
like backhander a couple times that's
where it's coming from and then I would
okay first I would confront both of you
guys at the same time what if he beats
you really really yes in the moment you
would run out to the parking lot uh no I
wouldn't run because
Bart is very logical he'll he'll not
when he's beating Geo yeah he will only
beat up Geo for a logical reasons
you got my back so me coming in I
oh
oh yeah yeah I started maybe acting like
a [__] he might like start punching me
but if I see it happen I would go up to
you guys and go hey like what's going on
oh [__] what was I doing
oh God oh God
I'm so clearly now
now I feel like if you did that if I I
just whooped on Geo like that and you're
like hey guys what's going on I feel
like Jill will suck you
see but then it would switch up the the
mood you know and then everybody at
least someone else is getting stuck yeah
yeah at least at least you're not the
one hurting if it was if it was Bart NGO
and like I was witnessing it I would run
over there I would confront it too I
don't know if I'm winning a sock but I'd
run over there because I'd be like that
dude would you go like this would you
like stop
I'd probably do a lot of yelling first
hoping that I wasn't gonna get punched
and stuff but yeah I'd probably jump in
there Jill's a friend too that's an
honest yeah yeah yeah yeah that that
would happen if I heard about it then
probably what I would do is I would hit
up Joe
and I'd be like Hey Joe I've been I've
been hearing some stuff and then I'll
see it and then if Joe knows if Joe
Knows then I'll be like Yo dude like
you're his best friend and then I'd be
like peace
wouldn't deal with it at all that's me
doing something you know and then when
Barton Geo are fighting outside and I go
out and bar smacks up I'll be like don't
let her bully you bar don't
don't
yeah because like a part of it is as
hard as it is especially if you're not
witnessing it a part of it is also like
um
it's like none of your business kind of
in one way you know what I mean if
you're not seeing it if you're just
hearing it you know what I mean if I'm
just especially if you have zero
relationship with the other person so I
guess yeah if I'm just hearing something
and that's my friend then I'll probably
still ask if I was I'm like hey I'm
hearing I heard that or somebody said
this about you I would probably ask you
know I mean I would ask if it's a friend
but it's hard because I wouldn't I
wouldn't be able to like uh to judge
them without knowing the context I
wouldn't be able to like dude you can't
be doing this [__] you know that's like
not my business and I don't know the
[__] facts if I'm not seeing evidence
of the girls [__] up right if I'm just
hearing about it no matter who I hear
from but hey this person's saying this
[__] about you you know what I mean
bring it up neutral like let's say if
Nick was I'd be like hey Nick can I talk
to you and be like uh hey I don't know
if you know but there's this thing about
you that's kind of going around people
are saying that you're being daughters
[__] out of two the whole time I'd be
deflecting making jokes
[Laughter]
it's just completely a different
character than your shower tip at the
house
no that's crazy I wouldn't do that but
it's a girl I mean not just girl but the
other partner is also a friend then it's
like that that's gonna get really
complicated you have to measure out a
lot of things I'm not saying I have a
generic answer for the situation but I
feel like that you'd have to take a lot
of variables but but it but like
intervention is still for sure yeah
physical abuse absolutely see the one
thing to like see it and then hear about
it like hearing about it is crazy let's
say either way you there's no doubt that
it is true if bar was being if I saw
Bart beat up Geo I'd probably tag in
dude I'm just kidding on which side yeah
I'm tagging with Barton no I might I
might get I think I the reaction would
be like
for me
I think I might get really upset at this
dude I'm like yo what the [__] yeah I
might I might do something like that
like if I saw something like that but
what if you get knocked out no dude
bro I'm tearing them up come on I don't
think me and you could do what Nick's
willing to do what if it was a stranger
okay so like all of this is just people
close to us right what if you're just
hanging out at the hotel and in the
hallway there's this guy you smacking
this girl around I'm ratting the [__]
out of him yeah I think that's when you
call the cops I don't want you to stop
would you go hey let go her would you do
that hey I'm going to stop you when you
don't do that was 16 I did really yeah
when I was six I was at my girlfriend's
house in her front lawn and then I'm
gonna probably try to also be macho too
because you're in that age whatever but
then we were like just talking in the
middle of the night and then there's
this like older like uh Hispanic lady
walking on the sidewalk and there's a
guy is creeping right behind her in a
van yelling at her like an older
Hispanic dude and he was just like
cussing at her throwing [__] at her whoa
and then
um I don't know maybe it reminded me of
my parents getting into fight whatever
so I immediately got up and then I ran
to the dude and I told no [__] do
that and then I guess he got scared over
and he he drove off you'd be like you
could beat her but do it in the house
keep it in your own yeah open the van
and I grabbed it up take this home
bringing back traumatic memories for me
they're triggering me dude I know that I
know
when it comes to like strangers having
domestic uh situations I have heard from
like cops that you don't get involved
yeah that's the thing you don't know so
many people yeah also I think when
you're a kid you're naive right yeah so
you just see one thing like protect all
women you assume but like you don't know
full context and they could be doing
that [__] every day like it ain't
nothing like the dude pulls out a gun or
some [__] you know yeah we just don't
know situations
she starts stalking you because you're
holding her dude like it's always just
they do that yeah oh that's a very
that's a very frequent thing I told the
story here but um I saw this like
homeless couple they're not homeless but
one of them he's a guy who like I've
seen around my block yeah and I see him
all over like Pasadena
but and he was like he was getting beat
up by his girl and I thought like dude
and then they're they're across the
street from me oh yeah and I just was
like yo chill like stop like stop please
stop and I don't know I should probably
shouldn't have done this I probably
should have just called the cops but he
was like call the cops man call the cops
and I was like
I don't know if I should call the cop
so I just I just went over there I went
across and like they were probably as
far as like Joe and can are for me oh
okay and I just was like I was like yo
stop like just don't
don't do that and then she was like
ripping his [__] shirt like trying to
Sock him and he was like trying to
restrain himself and I was like yo
please stop like what's wrong with you
yeah just don't do that and she's like
spitting on him and he's like yo bro
he's like she crazy dude like she crazy
and he's trying to like walk away and
then they eventually like I think
I just kept saying stop like please stop
like don't do this here don't do this
here and then they eventually separated
and walked away but it worked and I went
home and I was like I probably shouldn't
even done that I probably should have
walked into my house and like maybe call
the cops but I don't know dude but what
if she killed them dude you could have
stopped that I don't think I could have
stopped that dog
I don't know dude you said hey stop I
don't know if what I did was it I mean
we were talking strangers right is it
different if it's just two homeless
people like
you just leave when it looks like a
recurring problem I just leave it alone
yeah yeah you know what I mean because
I'm like this like yesterday next time
it's time but today I try to stop but
then tomorrow Joe tries to stop it's not
gonna stop like they have to fix their
own problems oh the next day I saw I saw
them at the uh the bus stop making out
hanging out no they were just sitting
they were sitting down with each other I
was pumping gas and they were like
and I was like Brenda that's the guy I
try to break us up
dude that's what it was it was ramping
up I feel like when you're younger right
all you think the the things are solved
so much quicker so you're more naive and
you have more Justice in your mind
you're like this needs to stop man you
want to be the police yeah
but then like you become older and you
see like your friend
calling on a domestic dispute thing like
from her boyfriend or whatever and then
they get even like a restraining order
and then they get back together and it's
just like why am I here for you like why
am I like like what are you doing yeah
and then you're like causing so much
drama because you just can't let go of
this relationship but then like it's
such a bad place to be or like there's
so many situations like that right like
where you would watch like a episode of
Cups and then like there's a domestic
violence thing that that you have to
like go answer a call do and then the
cops see this guy and then this girl
beat up and they're like oh he's got to
go to jail now and then she starts
hitting the cops like let them go yeah
and it's like what the [__] kind of
Stockholm syndrome [__] is this it
happens I had things recur too much and
then I start to feel that I care more
than this person that I have to walk
away yeah that's the key yeah because I
have a friend who's like kind of like a
not too close to me but she's like been
with this dude for many years and
um she just loves to update me and go
like guess what he did now and it's like
do you like this whoa it seems like it
proud of this like [__] update and
you're like what a Shiner that was yeah
it's like last time he broke my ribs
this time black eye it's like what the
[__] it's like she's showing off it's
yeah it's like a weird thing and that
you can really classify it as this you
just exist in this ecosystem now it's
not abuse anymore but you know I don't
understand the situation because you
know there's a lot of like weird things
um
no wow a love language
you're like a hostage on your own like
it's like you're you're like some people
that are um so like I have a family
member who grew up physically abused
beat up all the time from her dad right
so she got into a relationship with a
guy that beats her up and then she was
telling her sister like you know what's
weird is that I've been with other guys
safe guys good guys but I'm so Twisted
because of my father beating my ass but
also him being passionate and fun and
like he's she's like I kind of associate
this man it's comforting like with love
and then she's like I know it's [__]
up but like I feel the passion here
stronger than a guy that doesn't [__] me
up and I'm like so there's some kind of
weird like psychological thing that's
going on too like that I can't really
judge is that a disorder it's not a
disorder is it I don't know it's a
complex that's what Stockholm syndrome
is right but it's almost like so like
let's say uh if you grew up being abused
and you associate that as comfort
so like but that's like saying this is
not fruit this is my meat or he was so
like what happens a lot too is they
associate it as oh I deserve this I'm
not yeah the low self-esteem all that
[__] too yeah so I don't want to be like
blaming the victim but at the same time
someone's got to take responsibility for
their situation that they're in so if
it's like if you choose to continue and
you can't overcome your your fears of
leaving someone then that's like
something like no one else can help you
with I also don't believe that dudes
just magically stop hitting their girl I
don't think that's like a I think if it
happens
I turned over a new leaf and like
maybe not very easily at least but I've
never seen that firsthand you know I
think the only way most uh fathers stop
beating the [__] out of their kids is
when they become afraid of them yeah
that's like the main when they stand up
not because they just don't want to one
day yeah yeah they don't get tired of it
no in most cases they're forced to yeah
so I think it's the same thing with the
guys that keep beating the [__] out of
their girlfriends it's like what makes
you think one day they'll just magically
stop if you just wait patiently we knew
this uh we had a friend who would run
domestic violence like support groups
and it'd be like a like a
like a meeting with like a bunch of like
an AAA but for like yeah and they would
talk about like the patterns and they
all had the same patterns with their
Partners where the guys would hit the
girls or something like that
and then
they would start like
being really scared and like oh my God
I'm so sorry I did that and like kind of
curl up in a ball and like start crying
and like beg for forgiveness she should
then kick his ass while he's on the
ground they should do that but then
the uh the woman would like oh it's okay
no it's fine like you know and they
would and then uppercut yeah boom that's
what I should do but it becomes a cycle
of like I hit you I beg for forgiveness
then the woman forgives them and then it
continues again we can work on this blah
blah blah blah woman I like that woman
yeah
but then they would also see the um the
perpetrators the guys and what they
would do is they would understand like
the complexities of
like how to take advantage of this yeah
like they they they sit through like oh
yeah I'm trying to get treatment but
then they they become better at abusing
the system
it would get worse so it's like it's
like really [__] up so I don't know
and maybe that's not the right
um situation for them to like get better
no I think but it's uh it's it's a
pretty dark and twisted uh situation I I
personally think like because I remember
this one time we were all talking about
uh like some battered women's situation
and then there was like a bottom comment
way the [__] down in the abyss like it
was some girl saying wow a bunch of guys
trying to discuss women's issues and
like it's a man's issue too because it's
a man beating the [__] out of a girl
what are you talking about there's no
men involved we should turn the cameras
off we should talk I never engaged that
bottom con but I'm like this person I
need that [__] dumb like it's a guy's
responsibility first to get other guys
to not think that's cool like I think
that makes more of a difference if you
grow up in a circle of other dudes you
respect and they don't respect that you
won't respect that you'll just like
naturally go be ashamed that you're a
girl beater it's not cool yet yeah so
you guys have to influence each other to
be like no we don't roll like that
that's a guys but also guys have to
step in and protect women like that's
just the honest to God truth like if
women don't have guns or an equalizer or
the physical strength to restrain a guy
like we're not talking about [__]
WNBA women out here
um protecting their home girls you know
like they don't go to their games anyway
it's also yeah
huh yeah it definitely but it's also
it's also men out there have to know
that this is [__] up so then they have
the desire to step in it makes a bigger
difference than women asking men to not
do it to be honest yeah that's like
asking all of man to stop stealing from
liquor stores and it's like we don't
want to those are criminals that's like
like yeah you act like guys wake up one
day and go I can't wait to beat the [__]
out of women today right guys I think
guys have a better chance of convincing
other guys that certain things are not
the way you [__] her up I better I
guarantee you if a guy finds out that
another guy's like and and you threaten
them and you say if I catch you [__]
up my sister my cousin I'm gonna come
over and [__] kill your ass and then
they're like
okay I'll think about beating her
it's not even a straight no it's
all right enjoyable you know